[Música]
recentemente terminei minha pesquisa de
doutorado intitulada a ideologias e
inclusão educacional no contexto da
globalização
o motivo dessa pesquisa investigar como
discursos antagônicos estão presentes
nas mesmas práticas sociais ou seja como
discurso de inclusão e discurso da
globalização estão presentes no ambiente
escolar
essa inquietação ela dessa pesquisa ela
tem toda uma intimidade com a minha vida
pessoal porque eu sou uma pessoa com
deficiência visual
eu sou cega e sua primeira segue a
terminar o doutorado na unb no curso de
linguística
eu perdi minha visão há 17 anos e após
esse momento que o primeiro conquista
que eu queria era só o direito de voltar
a estudar
eu queria muito voltar a estudar apesar
de não saber como nem minha família e
após assistir minha mãe me levou no
colégio em que a própria diretora me
aceitou com algumas ressalvas disse que
ao não haveria nenhuma forma de
acessibilidade ninguém poderia me ajudar
em nada e que quis chegar um momento que
ela ia dizer que não seria mais possível
isso aí fica três tinha com isso o sol é
um diminutivo eu disse que não que eu
queria assim que ia tentar
e assim foi feito da mesma forma que ela
diz sem nenhuma forma de acessibilidade
é só minha família pra mim em casa e
após as primeiras avaliações ela me
chamou até a sala dela e perguntou já
com aquela pena né
é como você fez as provinhas você tirou
quanto na prova de inglês e eu respondi
que foi 9 meio e levou um susto que é 9
meio e chamou os demais professores para
saber como que seria com o que teria
sido a minha as minhas avaliações e
todos responderão a maior nota da sala
ela disse olha então decide diante disso
você pode ficar assim conquistei meu
direito de estudar e terminam o ensino
médio
queria nova etapa que ele
ensino superior em direito e letras e
diziam é impossível muita leitura
direito letras é muita leitura mas eu
conquistei esse direito de continuar
estudando
apesar de ainda ouvir muito o que ali
seria o fim só estudar mas não havia
direito de trabalhar não seria como não
dá nota não seria possível desenvolver
um trabalho e quando chegou o momento do
estágio a universidade queria me
dispensar o estágio e colocar aprovado
mas ali era um momento crucial para mim
ou eu mostrava que eu conseguia
trabalhar ou não ou dizer realmente
encerrava pra mim e eu insisti apesar de
eles negaram existir e disse até que
entraram com um mandado de segurança se
não me autorizasse
e assim eu conseguirei fazer mensagem e
ao fazer o estágio no dia nossas na sala
de aula o aluno levantou e falou a
professora é entre uma mulher que na
sala
a assentada no fundo eu imaginei que
seria meu professor de estágio tudo bem
e continuei a minha aula passaram dez
minutos o mesmo aluno bem falou o
professor a mulher levantou e saiu
chorando eu fiquei assustada foi nossa
que eu fiz né
e perguntei para a coordenadora da
escola quem era ela me confirmou que era
realmente a minha professora de estágio
e no dia seguinte na universidade essa
mesma professora me pediu perdão porque
ela realmente foi uma das pessoas que
quis me barrar e por que ela achava que
eu não tinha a menor capacidade de ser
professora e ela disse que daquele
momento ela jamais colocaria um limite
nas pessoas
nesse momento foi quando eu tinha agora
argumentos práticos que eu conseguir que
eu conseguia trabalhar e fiz o concurso
a professora de língua portuguesa no
estado de goiás não havia vaga para
deficiente
eu tirei a segunda maior nota do estado
em quando foi tomar posse o o o méxico
onde só uma professora cega impossível
impossível a professora cega a
deficiência incompatível com a sua cueca
com a sua profissão eu tentei argumentar
e ele não não de forma alguma
mas eu percebi que ele era irredutível
eu pedi que pra tirar cópia do documento
ele autorizou e que só que seria não a
copiadora em frente à junta médica ea
secretária do medley ele nos acompanhou
até a calçada ea outra vez errou
bastante movimentada qual a atravessar
essa rua eu percebi e que tiver pressa
acabou ficou do outro lado foi mãe da
moça ficou do outro lado a secretária
ficou e foi então corre corre e não eu
que correr porque eu não vou entregar
documento ocorre que embora ea gente se
ela me obedecer apesar de concordar que
eu falei um pega o primeiro táxi tiver
na frente a gente pegou o primeiro táxi
e fui com a secretaria de educação já
queria falar com o secretário de
educação
eu só quero fazer um acordo eu tenho
direito a tomar posse eu passei tive a
segunda maior do estado e tentarem
barrar mas eu tive muita sorte com o
chefe de gabinete do governador e estava
saindo lá do gabinete do secretário de
educação
quando ele ouviu o que eu dizia ele
falou coloca essa moça dentro da sala
porque isso pode ser muito problema para
nós é e eu entrei
contei toda a história o secretário de
educação e ele ouviu atento e disse
claro eu vou te ajudar você volta semana
que vem eu fui eu acho que não entendeu
a conta comigo é só hoje
semana que vem tem acordo nem amanhã em
acordo ou senhor me ajuda agora ou eu
entro com mandado de segurança e vou
atrás dos adversários políticos de vocês
vão gostar muito da minha história
ele percebeu que nunca eu sou eu estava
decidido que eu queria no meu objetivo
ela ele ligou para o médico e durante
ligação foi olha e diz que você tá com
um documento que você pegou e foi embora
eu peguei sentar comigo você tem que
devolver o filho não levou eu troco
eu venho de novo não aí ele falou assim
tá então ele autorizou eu fui lá na
junta médica o médico centavos em 1 100
tá muito satisfeito mas trocou o
documento comigo eu fui professora no
estado de goiás
e quando eu começo a política de
inclusão que a política de inclusão é
colocar todas as pessoas com deficiência
com qualquer tipo de deficiência
independente do grau no ensino regular
quando começou essa política foi chamada
e falar olha você tem que ajudar a gente
porque você tem muita experiência a
ensinar os professores os alunos como
que você fez pra alcançar que você
conseguiu que agora você já tem até dois
cursos superior você professora você
advogada
aí eu em bater um desespero eu pensei
que método pronunciamento nenhum eu não
sabia o que fazer
eu sabia que eu conquistei por teimosia
porque eu fui atrás porque eu encontrei
o meu caminho
mas aceitei o desafio e perceber que nas
escolas há uns não estava a situação
deles não era diferente pra mim eles
estavam na escola e não havia nenhuma
possibilidade
só que muitos não tinha determinação que
eu tive não tinha mesmo teimosia e
muitos desistiram e os proíbe ninguém
também da mesma forma comigo ninguém
sabia o que fazer mas que o discurso de
inclusão era o que a gente queria o
direito à escola era mas em que momento
que a gente falou que seria assim
radical
será que se eu tivesse métodos corretos
um sistema braille 1 e informática
acessível com tecnologias de
acessibilidade teria sido mais fácil
claro que sim
claro que não porque eu digo eu não
encontrei portas abertas nenhuma eu
roubei todas as portas e assim eu depois
eu pensei 'o o fifi fazer mestrado em
brasília passei no concurso da do
ministério da educação e trabalhei
diretamente com a política de inclusão e
ainda continuava a inquietação de onde
que esse discurso vem propor o fim da
escola especial que discute a inclusão
propõe essa inclusão radical
determinando que a escola especial
feição de serviço para a sociedade
e quando essa idéia de sabe descobrir
que que onde quer que esses que esse
discurso perdeu um pouco da voz às
pessoas com deficiência foi o que
motivou a desenvolver a minha tese e não
percebi que o discurso da globalização
em certo momento ele contra mim no
discurso de inclusão porque como porque
se um diz ao discurso à convenção
discurso muito melhor
a lista e acaba colocando a pé mas de
uma forma mascarada que a escola
especial ela prestou um desserviço à
sociedade e e e e de certa forma ele
molda o discurso de inclusão ea e só que
na verdade no não tem que haver um fim
de uma escola especial e no fim e e
somente ensino regular o que eu
desenvolvi na minha tese é que as duas
escolas podem estar ao mesmo tempo no
mesmo espaço no mesmo sistema
educacional desde que as duas sejam
inclusive aquelas duas promova uma real
inclusão porque é isso que as pessoas
com deficiência querem esse direito a
estudar o direito de estar na sociedade
mas de uma forma com acessibilidade com
todos os mecanismos que promovam
acessibilidade sem jogar fora toda
conquista que já foi feito porque essa
ideia que eu quero também que as as
minhas conquistas também sirvam de de
portas abertas para as outras pessoas
não é que é aquilo que eu conquistei não
seja fechado mas que outras
oportunidades como as metodologias de
ensino de forma acessível também silva
de fora é de suporte pra a educação das
pessoas com deficiência porque eu
conquistei o que eu conquistei sem
métodos
eu digo que é vale a pena sonhar vale a
pena e atrás aquilo que que seu coração
de disse que é possível mas se esse
sonho e já existir realizada na
realidade existe como prática de outras
pessoas com certeza esse caminho vai ser
mais fácil vai ser um caminho mais curto
e não vai ser só quem é teimoso que vai
chegar que vai conquistar um lugar até
mesmo quem tem um pouco mais de medo
também vai vai conquistar eu deixo um
recado não ouço uma voz do não o sempre
não vai atrás do seu sonho
mas deixe também o transformou em
realidade
permita que esse sonho seja real
é isso
[Música]